- [Dotson:] The one thing about me,
you don't have to coach my effort.
Ima give 110 percent when I step on the court.
[hip-hop music]
- [Announcer 1:] Spin move by Dotson!
- [Announcer 2:] Are you serious?
- [Announcer 1:] Dotson...
[whistle chirps]
[crowd cheers]
- [Announcer 1:] Dotson
gets a screen. Dotson!
- [Dotson:] I feel like the
reason why I'm entering the draft now,
um...the time is right, you know.
What I showed this past season,
talked to my coaching
staff, my family, and,
you know, I'm ready for
that next challenge.
That next step in my life.
- The longest draft process ever, right?
You know, I think we all know that.
But, you know, all in all,
it's been really good for him, I think.
This is probably the biggest gap of time
when he's really been
able to focus on himself
and his individual skill.
We're all anxious. We're
ready for November 18.
But I think it has been good
in that he's been able to work
on himself and get better.
- He's had to
endure a lot of patience,
a lot of flexibility,
but you know what, it's just
going to make him tougher
and that much more of a
pro at the next level.
[crowd cheering]
- [Announcer 1:] Dotson.
Yes!
- [Announcer 1:] Dotson leans in.
- Looking back on this Kansas
year, it was special.
We're number one in the nation
for three straight weeks.
We won the conference title.
That was our goal coming into the season.
- [Announcer 2:] Oh boy!
Dotson for three.
- [Dotson:] That late-game success,
I think it's just a natural thing
that I've always had since I was little.
I never wanted to lose in anything.
It could be a card game, Uno game.
I'm just never trying to lose.
- We played in the basement a lot.
And sometimes we'll play one-on-one,
and we get kind of rough
cuz, you know, we're pretty physical.
We both hated to lose.
So, we would kind of go
back and forth, get mad,
cuz one person fouled
each other too hard.
- I went to
the same school as him
when he was in middle school.
And he was, like, the star, you know,
of the basketball team.
That's when he started taking it seriously
cuz he was really good
at such a young age.
- Around sixth grade,
my older brother, actually, was
the reason why I got serious with it.
He's three years older than me,
and that's when he started
to get serious with it,
so I tried to follow in his footsteps.
And that's when things started to pick up,
started to see my game advance.
- He grew up watching Derrick Rose,
so that's kind of been the
person that he's watched
at an early age. And,
you know, he modeled a lot of his game
because he had quickness,
he had some explosiveness like Derrick,
how Derrick likes to attack the basket
and attack in transition.
And, you know, those are
the two biggest strengths
of, of Devon, is just
being able to beat his man
off the dribble and to
push tempo in transition.
[Body thudding]
- [Crowd:] Ohhh!
- [Announcer:] Oh!
[Crowd cheering]
[Buzzer buzzing]
- [Angela:] It's been
an incredible journey.
He's always played at a, a high level.
He's always been very competitive.
You know, all three, all three children—
you know, sports in general
just teaches a lot of life lessons.
- [Dalen:] My seventh-grade year,
which was his fourth-grade year,
we played on the same, like, travel team.
He was three grades behind me.
And I saw, like, how he was,
you know, competing with us,
competing with my peers,
competing with seventh-
graders at fourth grade.
So, at that time I knew, like, "Oh no,
he's pretty good in basketball
and I think that he could take it far."
- [Dotson:] Sports in general
has, has always been big in our family.
But basketball has kind of
taken the, the main focus.
My, my sister got into it.
My brother plays.
It's just a sport that we all love.
- [Dalen:] When we were playing one-on-one,
we would kinda like
visualize us, like, in the NBA.
So, we would, like, play
against the invisible team
as if we were an NBA team.
We would go back to our rooms,
like, get on the plane, do
interviews between games
and kind of just like
experience the whole NBA.
- It's been a long wait,
so it's going to be a
sense of relief almost.
Like, "Oh, we've, we,
we're finally here."
And just knowing where
your child is going to be
and grow and thrive.
- [Dotson:] What I learned most was
control what you can control, you know.
There's things that are going to be
above what you can control.
And as long as you stay
level-headed, stay locked in
and continue to work at it every day,
stuff should find its way.
The amount of work and amount
of dedication that it takes,
you know, you can't—I mean,
sometimes on the weekends
you want to go hang out.
Nah, you got to stay in
the gym, and, you know,
work overtime. But, you know,
I wouldn't trade it for anything.
- [Dalen:] As a big brother,
seeing my little brother
accomplish all his dreams
is definitely gonna be a proud feeling.
Yeah, I'm looking forward to it.
- You know, it's just been gratifying
as a dad just to see how
hard he's worked at it
and the benefits that
he's receiving from it.
- Just really grateful
for this opportunity,
and we know he's going
to do, do big things.
- For him to be able to live his dream
is not only inspiring,
but I'm just like genuinely proud for him
because I know that's
what he's always wanted
since he was little.